[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem sonntag die vom sport hat rudi
cerne hallo schön amt und wir haben
unter anderem diese themen für sie
in deutschland steigt die korona
inzidenz seit tagen wieder an
gesundheitsminister lauterbach
appelliert eindringlich dass auch erst
impfungen schützen
in den usa treibt omikron die
infektionszahlen zu neuen höchstwerten
die wirtschaft fürchtet einen einbruch
und doppel-erfolg für rodlerinnen beim
weltcup in winterberg holen die
deutschen platz eins und zwei
[Musik]
vorsichtiger optimismus nach den
feiertagen die omikron variante sei
wahrscheinlich etwas harmloser als
zunächst befürchtet sagt
gesundheitsminister lauterbach zudem
soll es möglichst noch in diesem monat
ein medikament gegen schwere verläufe
geben von entwarnung kann trotzdem keine
rede sein vor allem die millionen
ungeimpften seien in deutschland akut
bedroht alexandra vacano
das ende der weihnachtsferien am
berliner flughafen heute die urlaubs
rückreisewelle und damit auch eine
weitere infektionswelle der
gesundheitsminister sorgt sich 3,1
millionen deutsche über 60 sind
ungeimpft lebensgefährlich sei das so
lauterbach deshalb ich appelliere an
alle ungeimpften wenigstens diese erste
impfung zu machen denn damit also
reduziert man das risiko sehr schwer zu
erkranken oder gar zu versterben doch
schon deutlich also keine entwarnung
auch wenn omikron weniger schwere fälle
verursache trotzdem sind ärzte der guten
hoffnung dass das gesundheitssystem der
mikrowelle standhält wir haben die
hoffnung und das sagen ja auch viele
experten im moment dass wenn man die da
vergleicht die infektion dann die
immunität schafft wir gleichzeitig aber
mit dem gesundheitssystem insbesondere
den krankenhäusern nicht
überlastet werden das ist die hoffnung
doch es gibt weiterhin unsicherheit was
ist wenn omikron auf jemanden trifft der
jeder geimpft ist noch das virus bisher
durchgemacht hat und das ist eine sonne
situationen die wir in deutschland haben
insbesondere auch mit menschen über 60
jahren die wir so in südafrika und zum
teil auch in england nicht vorfinden
klar ist auf den intensivstationen sind
es bislang wenige omikron fälle unklar
ist wie hoch die omikron welle bereits
hierzulande ist der höhepunkt wird noch
erwartet die zahlen des lka bedingt
aussagekräftig wegen der feiertage die
sieben tage incidents sie steigt den
vierten tag in folge auf
222,7
steigende corona zahlen eine neue
infektionsfälle mit der omicron variante
darauf bereitet sich die bundesregierung
vor und der gesundheitsminister kündigt
jetzt den ankauf von einer million
packungen des medikaments packs gebiet
an das noch im januar zur behandlung
schwerer kopf 19 verläufe eingesetzt
werden kann
bei einer unangemeldeten demonstration
gegen die korona maßnahmen kam es in
greiz in thüringen wieder zu
auseinandersetzungen
polizisten wurden angegriffen als sie
versuchten die illegale versammlungen
mit 400 teilnehmern aufzulösen daraufhin
setzten sie pfefferspray und
schlagstöcke ein mindestens sechs
demonstranten und vier einsatzkräfte
wurden verletzt die pandemie
verschlechtert die zukunftschancen
vieler jugendlicher die zahl der schüler
ohne abschluss habe sich verdoppelt von
50.000 auf 100.000 sagt der präsident
des kinderschutzbundes hilgers der
rheinischen post zudem hätten viele nur
einen schlechten abschluss geschafft um
ihnen zu helfen fordert hilgers ein
staatliches programm für den umstieg von
der schule in den beruf
in den usa ist omikron bereits die
dominierende variante dort melden die
gesundheitsbehörden so viele
neuansteckungen wie noch nie beim
bisherigen höhepunkt vor knapp einem
jahr hatten sich durchschnittlich rund
250.000 menschen täglich mit corona
infiziert inzwischen sind es fast
400.000 neuinfektionen pro tag mit
massiven folgen auch für das öffentliche
leben aus washington berichtet matthias
in
amerika liegt lahm ein stückweit wegen
omikron täglich tausende von flügen
gestrichen weil viele piloten
flugbegleiter und wurden personal sich
krank gemeldet haben seit fünf tagen
sitzen ted und lieder boer in florida
fest
am montag habe ich wieder chemotherapie
das werden wir wohl nicht schaffen
in die freude über das neue jahr mischt
sich die sorge um die wirtschaft ja
sogar um es funktionieren der
gesellschaft in new york sind ein
fünftel der polizei war
darüber müssen wir uns sorgen machen
schließlich wollen wir nicht dass in
folge die gesellschaft zusammenbringt
morgen sollen in amerikas größtem
schulbezirk new york wie vielerorts im
land die schüler in die klassen
zurückkehren selbst wenn die fallzahlen
dann noch weiter in die höhe schießen
durch tests werden wir betroffene kinder
identifizieren und herausnehmen die
statistik zeigt wenn ein kind betroffen
ist gilt das nicht gleich für die ganze
klasse
die hauptnachrichten verbreiten derweil
hoffnung auf den wendepunkt in dieser
pandemie die schiere zahl von
infizierten durch omikron bei milden
verläufen könnte zur herdenimmunität
beitragen
ziemlich jeder bis frühling ein stück
immunität gegen das virus entwickeln es
gibt viele hinweise das ist schon im
februar besser werden könnte
schön wär's noch stehen sie hier
stundenlang an für selbsttests von denen
es viel zu wenige gibt ein mühsamer
jahresauftakt in amerika
alle aktuellen entwicklungen zur
pandemie in deutschland und weltweit
gibt es jederzeit nachzulesen in der
zdf- heute- app in einem corona
live-blog
spürbare steuerliche entlastungen
verspricht finanzminister lindner und
zwar mehr als 30 milliarden euro in den
kommenden jahren in der bild am sonntag
nennt lindner konkrete beispiele aus dem
koalitionsvertrag
etwa dass steuerzahler die beiträge für
die rentenversicherung
künftig voll absetzen können lob dafür
kommt vom mittelstandsverband die linke
dagegen spricht von einer umverteilung
von unten nach oben
das geldvermögen der menschen in
deutschland ist trotz pandemie weiter
gewachsen auf rund 7,7 millionen euro
ein plus von mehr als sieben prozent das
meldet die dz bank eingerechnet sind
unter anderem bargeld bankguthaben
aktien und lebensversicherungen zur
verteilung dieses vermögens auf die
bevölkerung gibt die bank allerdings
keine auskunft
in iserlohn sind auf einem friedhof
muslimische gräber geschändet worden
nordrhein westfalens innenminister ralf
sprach von einem abscheulichen
verbrechen in jeder religion sei die
totenruhe heilig unbekannte hatten auf
dem muslimischen teil des friedhofs etwa
30 grabsteine umgeworfen und
dekorationselemente beschädigt am
nachmittag kamen hunderte menschen
zusammen gemeinsam zeigten solidarität
mit den angehörigen der toten und
setzten ein zeichen für religiöse
toleranz
nach südafrika ein feuer hat in kapstadt
das parlamentsgebäude schwer beschädigt
der großbrand auf dem gelände mit
mehreren gebäuden war am frühen morgen
ausgebrochen
seitdem sind dutzende feuerwehrleute im
einsatz
teile des dachs und einige decken
stürzten ein verletzt wurde bislang
offenbar niemand warum das feuer
ausbrach ist noch unklar
und jetzt der sport rudi der diesmal
nicht mit wintersport beginnt kommt aber
auch noch aber zunächst tennis aus
australien sydney tennis olympiasieger
alexander zverev gewinn zwar sein erstes
einzel in dieser neuen saison muss aber
mit dem team eine niederlage beim atp-
cup einstecken in diesem
nachfolge-wettbewerb des tennis davis
cup verliert er das entscheidende doppel
an der seite von kevin krawietz gegen
großbritannien in zwei sätzen im ersten
match nach sechs wochen pause tat sich
zunächst schwer gegen die nummer 12 der
weltrangliste
kämmerin orie im vordergrund sagte
deutschlands sportler des jahres über
den platz hatte einen satzball und lag
vorn bis zu diesem herrlichen
ballwechseln mit tricks und wolle zum 55
danach wollte der brite nur noch zwei
spiele und zwar rechtlich mit dem 7 zu 6
und 6 zu 1 zum 1 1 für deutschland aus
musste aber auch zum doppel an der seite
von kevin krawietz antreten weil sich
dessen stamm partner tim pütz verletzt
hatte leichte fehler führten zur
schnellen 3 6 4 6-niederlage gegen
daniel evans jamie marie und dem 1 2
gegen großbritannien nun muss
deutschland dienstag gegen die usa
gewinnen
corona macht auch vor witz das nicht
halt der siebenmalige weltfußballer des
jahres lionel messi wurde positiv auf
das virus getestet
das gab sein klub paris st germain hatte
bekannt der 34 jahre alte argentinier
befindet sich wie drei andere spieler
des französischen spitzenklubs in
isolation
bobpilot francesco friedrich meldet sich
in sigulda in lettland eindrucksvoll
zurück heute kann er wieder jubeln nach
dem enttäuschenden zwölften platz im
zweierbob-weltcup gestern entscheidet
sich der doppel-olympiasieger in zweiter
zwei rennen für anschieber torsten marx
ist auch fahrerisch zeigt sich friedrich
konzentrierte und besser und feierte
seinen insgesamt
63 weltcupsieg und in starker form
präsentiert sich auch rennrodlerin julia
taubitz aus oberwiesenthal die
weltmeisterin setzt sich in winterberg
vor olympiasiegerin natalie geisenberger
durch und fährt zu ihrem vierten
saisonsieg mit einem starken zweiten
lauf verbessert sich taubitz vom vierten
auf den ersten platz und bleibt damit
auch führende im gesamtweltcup
jetzt hast du auch den wintersport
gehabt ja mit glücklichen gesichtern
vielen dank er fehlt noch der blick aufs
wetter das wird wechselnd bewölkt mit
vielen schauern längere trockene
abschnitte vor allem im osten und am
alpenrand starker im bergland
stürmischer südwestwind höchstwerte 8
bis 14 grad marietta slomka begrüßt sie
im heute journal um viertel vor zehn
hier übernimmt morgen yanar pareigis wir
sagen tschüss und wünschen ihnen einen
fröhlichen start in die erste woche
dieses jahres alles gute
[Musik]